nous sommes à présent en direct avec
philippe klein médecin chef de la
clinique internationale de hauranne
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france j'imagine que vous avez suivi de
près les premières conclusions des
experts de l'om est missionnée à g
comment est ce que vous les avez
accueilli bien déjà il faut savoir que
les experts de l oms étaient venus
l'année dernière à la fin du mois de
janvier à mourad donc ces équipes sont
déjà venus à houran et il faut leur
laisser le temps aujourd'hui de de
progresser dans leurs enquêtes j'imagine
aussi que les responsables chinois ont
eu le temps sur une année de se faire
une idée de l'origine de l'épidémie ici
à oman qui a débuté ouah de décembre
2019 lorsque le docteur lee wang liang a
observé cette no money atypique haouran
et qu'il a passé cette information à ses
collègues
est ce qu'il ya des raisons selon vous
de s'interroger sur la fiabilité des
conclusions qui nous apprennent n'a
finalement pas grand chose non plus en
sur l'origine de la pandémie à ce qui
est vraiment étonnant donc dans cette
dans cette enquête c'est que en 2002 3
2004 lors du premier sera ce lot oms et
le monde scientifique avait mis à peu
près une année pour déterminer le
l'animal réservoir la chauve-souris et
l'être humain
on peut penser qu'avec l'accélération
des connaissances en 2020 2021
on devrait avoir aujourd'hui des
réponses beaucoup plus rapide
concernant l'origine de cette de cette
épidémie ce n'est pas le cas c'est donc
qu'il ya d'autres phénomènes qui
interviennent et qui sont des phénomènes
board rarement la vie plutôt d'ordre
géopolitique et politique
ces considérations politiques liées à
cette réaction le département d'état
américain ces dernières heures qui
dénonce des conclusions basées sur tout
sauf la science sont les termes utilisés
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
ça m'inspire forcément une lutte une
lutte d'influencé entre deux grands
blocs qui qui qui notamment la grande
puissance chinoise qui émerge sur
laquelle on veut donner la
responsabilité de cette de cette
catastrophe humaine
moi moi ce que je peux dire en tant que
témoin puisque j'ai vécu toute cette
crise ici haouran c'est que j'ai vu mes
collègues chinois alors qu'on avait fait
le tour de cette épidémie au mois
d'avril prêt à vouloir aider le reste du
monde et donner une contribution au
reste du monde pour se sortir de cette
catastrophe humaine ils ont le
fonctionnement aujourd'hui d'être pointé
du doigt
il ya eu activement de culpabilité de la
chine puisque au départ les premiers cas
venaient à priori de deux ouvrages les
chinois ont fait ce qu'il fallait pour
empêcher le virus de venir en dehors des
régions du groupe ace sur le reste de la
chine je rappelle qu'il ya pas eu de
premières vagues dans le reste de la
chine en dehors de la région du roubaix
de ses 60 millions de personnes
donc à partir du moment où il avait fait
cet effort ils ont voulu tendre la main
en reste du monde
je pense que le reste du monde n'a pas
saisi cette occasion à partir de là il
ya eu un sentiment probablement de
fierté et de nationalisme ou du mot de
la chine vis-à-vis de ce comportement de
du reste du monde à moins de la
situation c'est aujourd'hui à orale est
ce que vous êtes sorti d'affaires ce que
la vie normale a réellement repris son
cours et bien en fait l'épidémie 7
les choix le choix qu'a fait la chine
c'est non pas de freiner l'épidémie mais
bien de la maîtrise et de l'arrêter et
le 8 avril 2020 le l'épidémie était sous
contrôle
how can alors bien sûr les chinois nous
n'ont pas repris une vie normale dans la
région du roubaix c'est 60 millions de
personnes bloquées n'ont pas repris une
vie normale il y avait une crainte une
peur terrible
les chinois ont dû utiliser la méthode
du testing au mois de mai
ouvert la population qu'on était
largement passer au dessus ou en dessous
du seuil épidémique est depuis le mois
de mai il n'y a plus eu de cas de deux
autochtones et d'infections à gourna
virus dans la région de l'oural et du
roubaix donc on peut dire que depuis le
mois de mai on vit haoran normalement on
se déplace on va travailler on va au
restaurant on va au cinéma
alors bien sûr il ya toujours sept cette
année cette absolue nécessité pour les
chinois d'empêcher le virus de revenir
sur le territoire national donc on
utilise les outils modernes que sont
l'intelligence artificielle que son on
utilise toujours le masque i see how one
pour se protéger et en fonction des
résurgences puisqu'on a vu qu'il y a
quelques semaines il ya eu des
résurgences au tour de pékin eh bien on
voit ces mesures se renforcer pour
absolument tout faire pour que
l'épidémie ne reprennent pas à en chine
quel regard est ce que vous portez alors
sur les mesures sanitaires les
restrictions qui sont privées en france
et bien tout tourne autour de la notion
de liberté semble-t-il
je pense que les chinois ont choisi une
solution de confinement qui a duré en
tout j'ai toujours dit 52 joue entre le
17 février et le 8 avril
donc 52 jours d'un confinement
extrêmement strictes associé à la
l'identification des personnes positives
et des contacts qui fait que ensuite on
s'est retrouvé dans une sorte de bulle
sanitaires donc cette privation de
liberté finalement elle n'a pas duré
longtemps
et moi je compare ça à cette privation
de liberté que l'on voit en l'occident
qui s'éternise où l'on se retrouve dans
une situation non pas de maîtrise mais
d'incertitude et il n'y a rien de pire
pour pour les citoyens du monde que
d'être dans l'incertitude et ne pas
savoir ce que sera le lendemain
merci beaucoup d'avoir fait tant de
réagir sur notre antenne filet plan
médecin chef de la clinique
internationale de uralde en chine
banques